là
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7 8 politique une
émission enregistrée au parlement
européen de strasbourg comme tous les
mois un eurodéputé francilien nous
accompagne pour une demi heure
d'émission ce soir jean marie cavada
eurodéputé centriste est notre invité
nous allons évoquer avec lui le rapport
dont il est le co responsable sur le
statut de lanceurs d'alertés voir
notamment si plus de transparence peut
permettre à l'europe de regagner les
coeurs des citoyens européens
durant cette émission nous allons
également découvrir l'un des pères
fondateurs de l'union européenne et
winston churchill connu pour avoir été
notamment le principal rempart face au
nazisme les syndicats en europe où
seront aussi expliqué vous verrez que
leur poids et leur rôle varie fortement
selon les pays
enfin les yvelinois auront la parole
dans cette émission puisque élus du
territoire et habitant interrogeront
notre invité sur la question de leur
choix
[Musique]
jean marie cavada bonsoir bonsoir à tout
le monde
vous êtes eurodéputé depuis 2004 membre
du groupe ici au parlement européen
alliance des démocrates et des libéraux
pour l'europe un groupe que l'on
qualifie notamment de centristes et
profondément pro-européen à votre
engagement politique vous avez une
longue carrière journalistique on va
revenir rapidement dessus vous avez
notamment présenter le journal de 20h
l'émission la marche du siècle vous avez
été aussi président de radio france
pendant sept ans dit nous est ce que vos
habits de journalistes vous manque un
peu avec notre nom non seulement ça
manque pas mais j'avais décidé ayant
fait à peu près le tour de tout ce qu'on
peut faire dans ce métier du journalisme
de badens huit responsables de rédaction
blanc suite responsables de chaînes
ensuite créateur de france 5
président entre successivement de trois
réseaux de télévision ou de radio comme
vous l'avez dit donc j'avais vraiment
pris toutes les armes du journaliste
pour regarder mon pays et regardez
l'europe mon pays dans l'union
européenne
et je voyais bien que l'un et l'autre
étaient en position de fragilité pour ne
pas dire de déclin c'est ce qui m'a
d'ailleurs convaincu de venir dans la
vie publique ce qui est ce qui veut dire
tout de même qu'aujourd'hui vous avez
peut-être une relation particulière que
les journalistes on va dire qu'il
s'intéresse aux aux affaires européennes
oui écoutez je sais surtout comment ils
travaillaient pour cause puisque j'en
viens mais ça s'arrête là parce que
chacun doit être dans sa place dans son
camp si je puis dire le vrai celui des
journalistes c'est de poser des
questions de d'investiguer de l'analyser
et le mien c'est de faire la pédagogie
de ce qui se passe ou ne se passe pas en
europe
jean marie cavada l'histoire européenne
doit forcément vous intéresser le vieux
continent c'est construire en grande
partie grâce au père fondateur de
l'après-guerre parmi eux on retient le
parcours d'un britannique
farouche opposant d'adolphe hitler et du
nazisme winston churchill les détails de
sa vie politique avec philippe le guen
directeur de l'association yvelinoise
jean monnet
[Musique]
c'est un homme qui en même temps était
un poète un romancier un écrivain de
talent qui avait une très belle plume et
ça lui a servi évidemment dans sa
carrière politique pour arriver dans la
chambre des communes le parlement
anglais a toujours être élu
et puis ils traquent tôt il a compris
que pas au début de la montée d'hitler
en allemagne très tôt il a compris qu'il
y avait danger
ce que vaut ce que beaucoup de la classe
politique britannique ne voulaient pas
croire ils voulaient croire que vous
pouvez vivre en paix après la première
guerre mondiale et que finalement il
clair n'allait pas se lancer dans des
dans une conquête militaire lui
churchill avait très bien compris que
c'était un futur dictateur et donc après
l'échec des négociations de munich
vous savez les britanniques et les
français avaient espéré la paix eh bien
il a bien compris et donc il a été élu
ensuite
premier ministre britannique au début de
l'après seconde guerre mondiale et c'est
là qu'on connaît le plus finalement la
carrière de churchill comme chef de
guerre qui avait prôné la résistance par
tous les moyens des britanniques face
aux allemands et puis
après la guerre il a pour un temps
dirigé mais pas longtemps le continuer à
diriger le pays
mais ensuite il a été battu aux
élections et alors là il a eu un
une vision européenne
on pourrait dire un petit peu puisqu'il
a été à l'origine du lancement du
conseil de l'europe
sa vision de l'europe c'était plus une
vision de pays qui s'unissent pour la
paix n'est pas qu'ils intègrent autant
leur ré politique que celle qui
finalement et a été conduite suite à la
ceca la communauté le charbon et de
l'acier puis ensuite le marché commun
sa vision et il était d'accord pour un
rapprochement militaire en particulier
un puisqu'il a et c t il avait dit
notamment que au moment de la première
idée de communauté européenne de défense
en 1953 il avait dit que ce serait bien
que la grande bretagne bien que non
membre de la communauté européenne de
l'époque s'associe à cela donc ils
voyaient plutôt cela comme un rempart de
la démocratie
d'une part pour s'unir éviter les
guerres et aussi pour lutter contre le
le communisme
soviétique puisqu'il était un farouche
opposant évidemment à l'urss
si les pays européens parvenaient à
s'unir leurs 300 à 400 millions
d'habitants connaîtrait par le fruit
d'un comme un héritage une prospérité
une gloire un bonheur qu'aucune
frontière ne limiterait
[Musique]
jean marie cavada on vient de découvrir
le parcours d'un des hommes politiques
les plus importants du xxème siècle qui
plus est britannique drôle de clin
d'oeil alors que la grande bretagne va
sortir de l'union européenne drôle de
clin d'oeil je le disais qui doit
j'imagine vous vous attrister hante
encore au fil connu votre formule drôle
de clin d'oeil mérite une explication
parce que vous êtes profondément dans le
vrai si je peux me permettre d'en juger
c'est l'homme de la déclaration qui a
incité les européens à s'unir et à
s'unir pour quoi eh bien c'était une
idée assez simple c'est est de
transformer des sujets de bataille de
querelles ou même carrément de guerre en
l'occurrence il s'agissait de la
domination et de la possession de
l'énergie le charbon l'acier
la domination du fleuve le rhin et la
moselle en quelque chose de positif
c'est à dire quand il ya conflit au
sommet autour d'une table au lieu de
s'envoyer des avions des canons et des
bateaux pour s'entretuer et la deuxième
guerre mondiale ayant été hélas
l'illustration de ce que l'humanité
pourrait faire de pire
le plus terrible il faut rendre grâce à
chercher le de son énergie en tout cas
vous vous serez d'accord avec moi
l'avons voté il ya toujours été quelque
part un peu méfiante vis-à-vis du vieux
continent ça semble être le cas de
beaucoup d'européens dans d'autres pays
désormais on en vient on énonce en lien
à notre rapport qui va nous intéresser
qui voit le jour en ce moment au
parlement au parlement européen sur les
lanceurs d'alert un rapport dont vous
êtes le co-rapporteur avec votre
collègue eurodéputé virginie et rosières
c'est un sujet les lanceurs dan est
devenu brûlant et notamment en europe
depuis la sphère luc slicks qui a permis
de mettre à jour les pratiques fiscales
un peu douteuse du luxembourg
cette affaire date de novembre 2014 nous
sommes désormais début 2017 il était
impossible d'agir avant selon vous doit
d'abord il aurait nous aurions dû agir
tout de suite je
j'ai demandé en son temps avant luc
slick il y à la sphère snowdon que d'un
de 2013 date de 2013 et j'avais demandé
à la commission de délivrer un passeport
européen à monsieur snowden qui vit vous
le savez dans la banlieue de moscou ont
dit dans une ambassade je crois et qui
au fond ne pourra pas remettre les pieds
aux etats-unis sous peine de sanctions
extrêmement graves voire peut-être de
risquer sa vie et pourquoi il fallait
protéger ce monsieur nous les européens
bas d'abord parce que c'est pas la peine
de faire des numéros de valeur si on
n'est pas capable vaka pas de les
appliquer et ce monsieur a pris au monde
entier notamment à nous européens que
nos entre guillemets allié américain
c'est vrai qu'ils ont été alliés pendant
la deuxième guerre mondiale un peu
tardivement mais ils sont venus que ils
nous ont espionné un et schlans massif
le monde entier y compris nos dirigeants
est donc ce monsieur a fait le travail
que les états auraient dû faire donc il
doit être protégé
mais naturellement la vertu n'étant pas
la première je dirais la première des
libraires des choses quand on a une
certaine couardise politique et c'était
le cas de cette commission
eh bien on n'a pas protégé monsieur
snowdon
puis arrive la sphère luc slicks dont
vous venez de parler bonbons faire très
clair tout ça aurait dû démarrer plus
vite les procédures sont très lentes
dans ce parlement
et puis bien évidemment mieux vaut tard
que jamais il faut bien dire la vérité
on désigne du doigt en l'accusant de
tous les maux luxembourg mais presque
tous les étangs participer à cette
combine en ayant des des banques
filiales et c'est qui presque tout le
monde est mouillé dans cette affaire par
conséquent il est temps d'y mettre un
terme en effet mais moi je refuse qu'on
accuse jean claude juncker comme étant
le ru le peu le gall de l ancien premier
ministre ancien premier duc charbon
comme le gall qui aurait fait ça en
douce non tous les états étaient de
grands intérieurs presque tous les états
y ont des intérêts faut dire la vérité
maintenant il est les choses bougent
aujourd'hui dans les choses bougent en
santé dans le monde
oui les choses vous re sein du parlement
antoine deltour j'ai écrit
au président du tribunal de luxembourg
pour exprimer mon soutien monsieur del
tour pour la même raison il n'avait pas
d'intérêt personnel à s'exposer comme ça
il a révélé des pratiques frauduleuses
il ya beaucoup il n'y a pas que le
luxembourg en europe et à l'autriche
il ya les pays bas notamment il ya pas
mal
il n'y a pas mal il ya les îles anglo
britannique il ya pas mal de paradis
fiscaux auxquels il faut mettre un terme
et protéger les langes hurd alerte il
n'en est que trop temps
petite précision sur le rapport dont
vous êtes le co-rapporteur c'est ça a
valeur d'initiative législative
alors petite précision peut-être pour
ceux qui ne connaissent pas le jargon
ici au sein du parlement
ça veut dire que en gros c'est pas
contraignants comme en rapport la
commission européenne ensuite pour en
faire ce qu'elle veut peut-être rien
alors une initiative législative c'est
une proposition dans la commission pour
laquelle on doit se mettre d'accord avec
la commission
en fait cette idée elle vient de loin
quand on a fait un texte sur les secrets
d'affaires
j'avais personnellement introduit dans
ce texte les secrets d'affaires ça avait
pour but de protéger le savoir faire des
petites et moyennes entreprises
c'est pas un secret pour personne ne
sache qui se passe contrairement à ce
qu'une partie de la presse française a
dit d'ailleurs est en réalité j'avais
introduit la protection des lanceurs
d'alert une deuxième chose la protection
du pouvoir d'investigation et de
reportages des journalistes y compris
dans les entreprises qui ne sont pas des
lieux sacrés c'est des lieux qui
participent à la vie
donc oui donc ya pas de raison que les
journalistes souhaitent un caddie de ce
jour là dedans est là et ce texte était
très incomplet et on a vu qu'il fallait
revenir dessus et donner un statut aux
lanceurs d'alerté cette question très
difficile fait qu un lanceur d' alerte
quand vous parlez de statut c'est un
statut juridique pour définir ce qui est
véritablement à lens en alerte selon
vous c'est quoi alors alençon le procès
d' antoine deltour à luxembourg la
justice luxembourgeoise a pris applique
la loi luxembourgeoise
si la silla lois européennes
définissaient ce qu est un lanceur
d'alerté définissez les conditions de sa
protection la juste les sultans bon
chose qu'on me dira je n'accuserai plus
antoine deltour et c'est quoi un lanceur
d'aller c'est très difficile parce que
en fait ça à légiférer là dessus alors
de novembre 2000
c'est là la france a commencé à
légiférer en introduisant dans la loi
sapin de 1,10 en inde et que des
considérants des amendements qui voit là
et des articles qui définissent c'est
vraiment difficile à définir parce qu'au
fond on est dans la dérision général
c'est quelqu'un qui hors de tout intérêt
privé mais sur la place publique de
mauvais comportements du point de vue
financier
du point de vue des états et peut-être
du point de vue de la santé
la chercheuse de de rennes qui a proposé
à l'infra chance cantal du scandale du
médiator absolument qui a mis madame
irène frachon qui a mis sur la place
publique les méfaits du médiator est un
lanceur d' alerte pour moi mais il faut
pas non plus que ça tourne à la délation
dans les entreprises c'est là la
principale difficulté la ville
ouais et pour l'instant je consulte
beaucoup les avocats consultés jury je
consulte un certain nombre de gens y
compris d'ailleurs les comment dirais-je
des analystes politiques c'est à dire
les gens qui ont une vue sur
l'organisation de la cité les fondations
de sens politique et autres pour qu'on
arrive à un curseur qui protège les
vrais l'ancien tallec mais qui
n'encourage pas la délation gratuite
comment se passe d'ailleurs le travail
puisque vous avez été désigné au mois de
novembre et début novembre oui vous vous
rencontrez du coût des avocats des des
spécialistes de la scène alerte peut
être aussi nous rencontrons en ce qui me
concerne oui
mais nous rencontrons des gens de toutes
celles de toutes ces catégories que vous
venez dénoncé pour se faire un jugement
il ne pas faire une loi qui soit hors
sol parce que ça c'est la tendance des
parlement qui légifère à tour de bras
les lois s'appliquent ne s'applique pas
d'ailleurs on vérifie pas toujours celle
son bien ou mal appliquées ou pas
appliquées du tout et donc il faut là
dedans beaucoup je dirais deux mesures
il faut de l'exigence ça suffit
maintenant que l'on mette en péril la
vie où la liberté des danseurs de l'air
mais aussi de la modération pas
n'importe quoi la délation c'est une
boîte de pandore que tout le monde peut
couvrir que personne ne s'est refermée
la france en sait quelque chose
l'une des pistes envisagées est évoquée
notamment dans la presse européenne
c'est la création d'une autorité
européenne indépendante qui déciderait
si tel ou tel cas relèvent du statut de
lanceurs d'alerté ou pas c'est vrai ça
ça semble aussi aller dans le bon sens
est une piste intéressante en tout cas
parce que c'est une responsabilité
tellement grande que je ne voudrais pas
être seul à l'écrire et du coup 7,7
ce qui fait que cette entité aurait du
coup je dirais ce tel cas c'est long ça
n'a l'air tel cas ça ne l'est pas et
ensuite s'impliquerait quoi du coup ma
s'impliquerait coeur entre d'une
protection
oui voilà entre un système de comment
dirais je il ya une sorte qu'il y aurait
une sorte de l'audition puis une sorte
de mise en route du statut de lanceurs
d'alerté de la protection qui va avec
tout ça est encore assez flou je dois
vous le dire parce que toute façon le
parlement arriva renouvellement de ses
responsabilités afin est arrivé il ya
quelques il ya quelques temps la halle à
la mi-janvier à la protection à la
remise en cause par dans toutes ses
libertés de toutes ses responsabilités
puisque le parlement européen fonctionne
la manière suivante un mandat de cinq
ans et au bout de deux ans et demi a mis
mode à toutes les responsabilités sont
soumises à nouveau au vote
du coup ça ça fait un peu râlant sur le
processeur à lentille processus c'est
vrai avec votre expérience vous de
journalistes expliqué nous dit nous
peut-être dans vos souvenirs
mémoire à vous dans votre mémoire vous
est-ce que vous avez ce que c'est un
sujet nouveau les lanceurs d'alerté
parce qu'il y en a eu tout le temps et
finalement c'est un sujet qui prend
l'ampleur aujourd'hui mais qui a
toujours existé
vous savez monsieur les lanceurs d'alert
c'est à dire des personnes qui prennent
sur eux de dire publiquement le mauvais
comportement d'organisation de système
ou autre c'est vieux comme la bible et
l'humanité c'est pas nouveau du tout du
tout du tout ce qui est nouveau c'est
que aujourd'hui presque tout le monde
sait tout instinctivement de par la
circulation de l'information le
numérique et tout ça et qu'il faut
organiser je dirais une pensée
raisonnable et sérieuse il faut pas que
tout le monde soit désigné n'importe
comment
c'est une notion très grave après tout
ce sont des gens qui tout seul les mains
nues se pince porte sur la place
publique pour défendre l'intérêt général
ses terres la population où les
populations donc ou mais il y en a
toujours eu bien entendu bien entendu
qu'il y en a toujours eu en termes de
calendrier quand est-ce que selon vous
on aura un statut européen du lanceur
d'alerté ce que c'est du moyen du très
long terme moyen terme compter une bonne
année une année et demie parce qu'il va
y avoir de grosses pressions de
contestation les groupes politiques ne
sont pas d'accord tout il ya des
intérêts cachés derrière qui va falloir
mumbai pourrait bloquer un tel sujet
c'est quoi ces les dirigeants
d'entreprise ce sont certains
eurodéputés les gouvernants mais d'abord
les gouvernements il ya des
gouvernements qui ne veulent surtout pas
entendre parler sans cesse et c'est là
c'est le sage chinois
j'ai rien vu je n'ai rien entendu et je
ne dis rien et ça ça concerne tous les
gouvernements une partie bien sûr il
serait tout à l'heure ce n'est pas
uniquement le luxembourg uniquement le
nom les pays bas ça peut être aussi la
france espagne italie les pays des
mégots sait pas quand c'est pas le
mauvais comportement d'un gouvernement
comme ce fut le cas des états unis qui
ne gouverne pas les agents de sécurité
c'est l'inversé les agences de
renseignement qui gouverne c'est à dire
on a encore bien vue de la campagne
clinton trump est bien quand c'est pas
un gouvernement
ça peut être des entreprises ça peut
être une organisation même une ong n'est
pas forcément à l'abri dans son passé
tous ne sont pas vertueux ils seront
pris avec l'argent vous êtes sujet a
peut-être dépression nous quoi y'en aura
énorme elles vont être énormes
vous savez avec votre expérience vous
êtes prêts à cela
bon écoute est prêt il n'y a aucune les
pressions vous savez on en fait vraiment
des montagnes mais la pression si vous
n'avez pas d'intérêt personnel à quoi
que ce soit vous n'êtes pas vulnérable
bon moi mes chaussons savons connais ma
carrière deuxièmement je suis payée par
le parlement point final bon voilà donc
on peut faire pression tant qu'on veut
ça va pas changer grand chose
indiquons également petite précision que
pour le moment cinq pays européens
disposent d'une protection juridique on
le disait le la plus récente c'est la
france depuis le mois de novembre il y à
un modèle donc vous vous inspirez dans
ces pays là qu'on établit un statut
peut-être un pays qui est en avance sur
ce sujet on parle de temps en temps de
la suède puis depuis longtemps mais ce
que j'aime bien dans dans votre dans
votre comment dirais je
dans le sommaire de votre émission si
vous vous intéressez à des pays voisins
non français ce qui m'a toujours frappé
c'est que la france qui a besoin de
faire des réformes ou d'inventer quelque
chose plutôt que de dire du haut de son
arrogant jacobine voici ce que nous
allons inventer ou faire regardons donc
comment les autres pays autour de nous
ont eu les mêmes problèmes et les ont
résolu alors en effet les pays nordiques
m'inspire beaucoup dans cette affaire
d'ailleurs je vais y aller mais me
déplacer parce que je veux avoir de
longues conversations avec ceux qui ont
mis en place cette affaire mais en effet
c'est pas par hasard
naturellement ces pays sont petit en
terme de géographie et de population
mais ce sont de vraies démocraties avec
toute la lourdeur que ça peut comporter
mais toute la satisfaction que ça
apporte aussi on continue à s'intéresser
à nos voisins avec notre rubrique et
chez nos voisins ça se passe comment
aujourd'hui zoom sur les syndicats en
europe dans quel pays ont-ils un rôle
primordial à quoi sert-il elle les
précisions d'olivier jeannois ex
responsable du centre d'information
europe direct à saint germain en laye
c'est quand même assez différent en
fonction du pays donc en france on a un
taux de syndicalisation qui a à peu près
de 8% le taux maximum au niveau européen
il est 80% et là c'est en islande
alors sachant que pour les pays de
l'union européenne on est aux alentours
de plus 70% notamment dans les pays du
nord
alors après ce qu'on a constaté c'est
que depuis plusieurs années on a une
diminution du taux de syndicalisation
dans les pays du nord donc tout ce qui
est par exemple suède finlande danemark
belgique il ya un taux de
syndicalisation qui est très fort parce
que tout simplement les syndicats jouent
un rôle très important dans la vie
sociale des employés c'est eux qui verse
les aides au chômage et les aides
sociales
sachant qu'après la puissance d'un
syndicat ne dépend pas forcément du taux
de syndicalisation de d'un pays par
exemple on peut prendre le cas de
l'autriche où il ya 28 % des employés
qui sont syndiqués mais en fait il ya qu
un seul syndicat chez eux et c'est tout
ce syndicat alors il a ce qu'on appelle
un taux de couverture c'est-à-dire donc
l' influence
l'influent ce que va avoir les décisions
il a un taux de couverture qui est de 95
% des employés donc voilà 28% qui
influencent 95 % des employés ça reste
quand même quelque chose assez important
après on peut prendre l'exemple aussi
des pays des pays anglo saxons ou a
depuis fait cher on va dire que les
grands syndicats
les grands syndicats généralistes tels
qu'on connaît en france ont beaucoup
moins d'impact et c'est qu'en fait tout
simplement en la matière les
revendications se porte davantage au
sein de l'entreprise
donc c'est des petits syndicats qui
n'ont pas forcément une très qui n'ont
pas forcément un grand impact au niveau
national mais qui vont voilà avoir un
grand rôle à jouer au niveau de
l'entreprise
vous me disiez avant cette émission on
va juste rapidement réagir sur sur les
syndicats en europe que c'était un sujet
qui vous intéressez vous pourquoi les
syndicats vous intéresse-t-il en europe
et notamment le modèle danois
ce qui est très intéressant c'est
d'abord d'avoir la vraie photographie de
notre pays nous avons un système
syndical qui a je dirais toutes les
contradictions
un syndicat puissant donc trois ou
quatre d'entre eux au moins en france
sont capables de bloquer les transports
de peu sur quelque chose qui ne leur
convient pas et de soulever une
catégorie professionnelle de l'inviter à
aller dans la rue de manifester mais si
l'on regarde de l'intérieur ces
syndicats qui ont une capacité de
blocage nous représentent pratiquement
personne 5% dès salariés privés 11 % des
salariés du public ou pas pourtant on ne
risque rien de ce syndicat lui a
forcément en allemand c'est pas le
consuel c'est pas le con danemark ce
n'est pas le cas en allemagne autrement
dit nous avons la contradiction d'états
majors syndicaux bloquant avec une
représentation d' aucune légitimité
syndicale extrêmement faible il faut
donc régler ce problème parce que sinon
un jour on aura de très graves
distorsions et explosions je suis
partisan mois que l'on que l'on modifie
l'organisation des syndicats un peu à la
danoise c'est à dire que si on est
syndiquée on a des avantages de
protection sociale plus fort que si l'on
n'est pas syndiquée exemple le chômage
c'est vous êtes chômeur au danemark et
bien votre votre indemnité de chômeurs
sera plus importante si vous êtes
indiqué que c'est vous ne l'étiez pas et
c'est ça que j'appelle ça faire une
offre sur le marché de la protection
sociale à travers les syndicats il faut
leur confier des responsabilités et les
amener dans la négociation sociale par
entreprise ou par branches comme c'est
le cas et pour que ceux ci marche il
faut que l'état se retire de cette
affaire et se contentent non pas de
faire les textes mais d'encadrer le banc
de fonctionnement et non pas de diriger
le syndicalisme ou la position
gouvernementale avec le medef qui sont
les mêmes c'est un sujet dont qui vous
intéresse énormément
cette émission se veut aussi interactive
l'europe fait souvent l'objet de
reproches trop complexe pas assez
transparents voire inutile selon les
critiques
eh bien nous donnons la parole et c'est
là qu'on utilise la tablette on donne la
parole à des acteurs de la vie locale
pour vous poser une question sur
l'europe une question de
soit écouté cet habitant de
voisins-le-bretonneux une commune des
yvelines vous avez juste à appuyer sur
le bouton play et ça va se mettre en
retour et bonjour pascal domange voisins
le bretonneux dans les yvelines
donc moi ma question c'est en tant que
député qu'est ce que vous pouvez faire
pour agir sur l'harmonisation fiscale et
aplanir en fait les différences de
compétitivité qui entre certains pays en
particulier quand on voit ce qui se
passe en irlande et la france voilà
alors vous avez entendu cette question
sur l'harmonisation fiscale c'est un
vieux rêve peut-être
ou alors c'est un projet qui va voir le
jour là aussi on a imaginé un jour le
même taux d'imposition en france en
irlande c'est pas qui va voir le jour
c'est qu'il est en route
il est dans les tuyaux d'une part de la
commission européenne à travers
moscovici qui s'en occupent assez
sérieusement et d'autre part au
parlement où nous pensons que nous
devons inventer
je suis d'ailleurs l'auteur de cette
formule en france depuis très longtemps
depuis presque depuis six ans ce que
nous appelons le serpent fiscal comme il
lui autrefois dans les années 60 62 113
74 le serpent monétaire
vous savez quand un pays avait avait une
monnaie élevé à un autre une monnaie
faible est bien petit à petit on les a
rapprochés pour que pour qu'il n'y ait
pas de grands déséquilibres monétaires
sont de conclure hui sur le continent
européen et surtout des déséquilibres
qui coûtait beaucoup d'argent et bien ce
serpent monétaire a très bien fonctionné
et bien il faut faire la même chose pour
le serpent fiscal entre les pays qui ont
la plus petite fiscalité monsieur a dit
avec raison l'irlande 1 et ceux qui ont
la plus haute fiscalité entre
parenthèses nous les français eh bien il
faut par petites étapes de façon à ne
par fichier par terre les budgets parce
que le budget c'est ce qui permet de
vivre
année après année eh bien on va dire que
chaque année ou tous les deux ans ou
tous les trois ans on monte d'un cran
les plus faibles en descendre d'un cran
les plus élevés alors simple les plus
élevés alors descendre d'un cran ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire diminuer les
recettes fiscales d'un état ça veut dire
vivre un peu plus modestement dont vous
faut-il maigrir et ou ne faut-il pas à
maigrir en ce moment il ya de grands
débats sur le nombre de fonctionnaires
je trouve que plutôt que de se jeter des
anathèmes à la figure faut regarder là
où nous manquons de fonctionnaires
l'enseignement la santé la police la
justice est là où nous n'avons pas su
faire maigrir dans les régions et dans
les administrations centrales qui ne
savent pas tenir lors de la révolution
informatique mais oui avec libre âge à
faire car l'harmonisation fiscale dont
parle monsieur qui est absolument
indispensable
il le dit avec raison ça ça pour premier
première conséquence de d'apprendre à la
france à maigrir elle dépense 57% de sa
de sa richesse dans la dépense publique
bas il faut descendre vers 48 49
ça va prendre du temps mais c'est pas
grave que ça prenne dix ou quinze ans
c'est pas grave il faut entamer le
mouvement pour éviter les
délocalisations notamment
merci jean marie cavada d'avoir
participé à ce 7,8 politique version
europe ici au parlement européen de
strasbourg je rappelle que vous êtes
eurodéputé centriste d'île de france
mango parlement du groupe alliance des
démocrates et des libéraux pour l'europe
vous pouvez retrouver cette émission
replay sur tv fil 78 ou sur
l'application mobile tv fil 78 prochain
à 7,8 politique dans deux semaines merci
merci
[Musique]